Norma Donald but supposed to be on The
Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon last
night but these show canceled his
appearance after the interview he gave
to the whole reporter that was released
yesterday yeah in the interview norm
said that he's happy the me to movement
has slowed down and he says that he
actually got louis c.k who admitted to
sexual misconduct last november to call
roseanne after she was fired from her
sitcom this past summer now norms idea
was that Louie could relate to Roseanne
as both had lost their careers in the
course of 24 hours yes so this is like
norm said to THR of course people will
go what about the victims do you know
what the victims didn't have to go
through that they both said they had a
good conversation and we're just giving
any advice you could give to each other
there would be no way for me to even
understand that advice because who has
ever gone through such a thing all that
work in their entire life being wiped
out in a single day a moment yeah now
yesterday norm was actually already at
The Tonight Show ready to tape his
appearance when this story broke and
Jimmy Fallon actually went in and spoke
to him saying that they would have to
address this situation on-air but then
Jimmy later came back to say the
producers were really upset over the
idea of putting norm on air at the time
so Jimmy told norm that he wouldn't be
on the show
yeah the Norden issued an apology on
Twitter saying Roseanne and Louis had
been very good friends of mine for many
years they both made terrible mistakes
I would never defend their actions that
my word sounded like I was minimizing
the pain that their victims feel to this
day I'm deeply sorry I'm I'm it's funny
I think any other show would've still
had him on I think Jimmy Fallon has
obviously gone through this where he
hasn't handled situations well so I
think you know it's Stephen Colbert a
Trevor Noah would have still had him on
they would adjust it I think it would
have been better for an or McDonald to
get on camera and talk about this guy
think part of the reason that quote it
is in print and I think the way he says
yeah it does I get what he is saying it
makes sense you know
if you're friends of these people he
can't just completely abandon them you
want to reach out them but what he says
it makes it sound like he's saying that
what the victims went through isn't as
bad as what Louie and Roseanne went
which is a terrible thing that's saying
I don't think that's what he meant but
that's how it comes off in print this is
why Jimmy Fallon will never be a
late-night legend right because the
people who work that show and that
network
have they don't trust him yeah and they
know that he is one wrong move away from
an interview with nor McDonald to
completely destroying the show and all
of their jobs I don't believe for a
second that it was producers that felt
uncomfortable that Norm was gonna be on
the show I think it was producers that
felt uncomfortable giving this to Jimmy
Fallon right to potentially destroy what
little show that they have left at that
point so that's what it was you know it
just happened so no producer on a show
would have Norma Connell sitting in a
green room having just said what he said
in his interview Twitter on your show
like the number five trending thing on
Twitter in your green room and you tell
him to go home
no one says I don't like Jimmy Fallon
yeah Linda says just really Wow then you
have canceled his parents yeah I think
it's yeah just they should have gone
through then Jimmy should have been able
to handle it but yet stupid he can't and
that's why Jimmy will never be home is
kind of because if you've Norman gone on
camera right away yeah could have yeah
really like tone this down but yeah now
you don't get a chance to